marc nos 420 habitants en 2014
jacky faivre mer depuis deux mandats est
obligé de rempiler
faute de candidats moi je n'ai pas
tellement le choix à un moment donné il
fallait prendre la décision parce qu'on
avait personne pour l'équipe patch 3
mandats
basta pas de quatrième non non non non
non c'est en route chez pour souffler
allez on repense aussi cette année
la suite a été préparé c'est alain gava
déjà conseiller municipal qui devrait
lui succéder
actuellement je suis en contact avec la
le conseil départemental pour obtenir
des aides
je transmettrai à l'aller on ira
peut-être entendu je pense que si on a
peur alain gaba en retraite depuis un an
veut relever le défi et même les
relations quelquefois tendues avec les
administrés ne lui font pas peur
donc j'étais arbitres de rugby pendant
une vingtaine d'années j'étale 8e faire
1 disputée sur le bord des terrains
je m'y attends direction et clan nenon à
30 km de là en 2014 personne pour être
mère puis un habitant du village qui se
dévouent ensuite son conseil municipal
s'oppose à son projet d'accueil de
migrants
il démissionne il vit à 18 mois jacques
isa sympa lui succède
ce qui m'a donné envie c'est de te
découvrir un petit peu ce qu'était cette
fonction de maire parce que ça me
paraissait au départ quelque chose de
de compliqué et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que je voulais connaître un peu
plus mon village ses habitants pour
l'aider le maire inexpérimenté avoue
compter sur la secrétaire de mairie et
des salariés de la structure
intercommunale
le grand dole ravis de cette expérience
il veut continuer et cette fois ci pas
de problème pour trouver des candidats
souvent ce sont les gens qui sont venus
me demander venu venu à moi plutôt que
moi moi j'aï les chercher c'est bien ça
ça prouve qu'il ya déjà une motivation
là derrière quand même l'un part l'autre
reste
mais quel que soit le résultat des
élections cette fois ci ces deux
communes jurassiennes auront leur mère